rail safety is a top priority as eu
transport ministers meet in luxembourg
on october 10.
the ministers want to agree on a common
approach toward new
safety rules he aims to help create
economies of scale on rail projects
across europe
and simplify the procedures for issuing
safety certificates
current rules date from 2004 the plan is
to move toward a single eu safety
certificate
and do away with the need for national
rules the roles of national rail
authorities
and the european railway agency are to
be reviewed too
airline passenger rights and europe's
air traffic control system are also high
on the agenda
the ministers will debate the kinds of
protection that might be offered to
passengers who miss flight connections
while not discouraging air carriers and
tour organizers
from offering a wide choice of routes
and ticket combinations
on top of that they'll look at how to
regulate compensation for long flight
delays
council is also expected to decide
whether to extend a key project on
european air traffic management research
by
eight years until the end of 2024.
maritime transport is also up for
discussion notably pollution at sea
the ministers want to reach a common
position on a proposal for financing the
activities of the european
maritime safety agency with a focus on
combating marine pollution
for the next seven years the agency has
been in operation for a decade
the budgetary ceiling for its
anti-pollution activities until 2020
could reach just over 160 million euros